- I heard you just got
your driver's license.
- I did.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] That amazing!
Were you afraid to get yours?
I was a little afraid to get mine
'cause I was afraid of other drivers.
- Right. I was afraid of myself.
(laughs)
I mean I think my mom, my
mom was so afraid for me.
Like she was just like,
"You are too distracted.
You, just too much Pisces
energy to be on the highway."
And so I was like, "Yeah,
you're probably right.
You're probably right."
But then I was like, I think
I, I spent so much time
like feeling like I was
like really, really young.
And then I think the driver's li-,
like me getting my driver's license
was part of me being like,
"You know, I trust myself."
- I'm a grown woman.
- [Camilla] I'm a grown
ass woman. I can do this.
- Watch this, watch this.
- [Camilla] Yeah.
(audience cheering)
- Mine wasn't ever me.
I was always afraid of other drivers
and like big highways
with like mixed masters.
I was like, bridges, I
don't think I breathed.
- I'm still scared of highways
though. Like I drove here.
And every, every time
I drive on the highway,
I'm like, you know how, like on the maps,
it's like the option without the highways.
And then I'm always like,
"Damn, it's like twice as long."
But the whole time I'm on the
highway, my butt is clenched.
I'm like, "Today, it's
a day I'm gonna die."
- [Kelly] I'm gonna (laughs)
- Today is the day.
- [Kelly You did it. You made it.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] We're proud of you.